so the first speaker you're gonna hear
today is omnipotent Thompson the founder
of poppy poppy is a site that connects
parents with great caregivers for their
children so Omni and her co-founder went
through Y Combinator in winter 2016 and
she's also an incredible advocate of
this Seattle startup community and Omni
is really one of the main reasons we are
here today so so welcome Avni it's just
so amazing to see you all here today it
is amazing for me to have the FFC up
here for those of you that know me and
my story the female founder conference
is an important part of my story and
I've just always loved the energy when
you get all of these incredible women
together with ideas and big bold visions
it just lots of impressive things can
happen so I'm Omni I'm the co-founder
and CEO of poppy our mission is to build
the modern village that every family
deserves and we do this by connecting
these talented vetted caregivers to
families when they need childcare and on
the caregivers side we find amazing
folks that have a passion for and it's
health for childcare and we connect them
to families so that they can make some
extra income on a flexible schedule and
it's beyond just your average kind of
sitters and nannies these are teachers
and stay-at-home moms they can be dance
instructors and camp counselors really
just incredible people that have a
passion and experience in childcare and
then we connect them to families as
their safety net
this is pretty exciting to me because
I'm a parent my husband and I have two
little girls SIA is almost six and Aria
is three and we have been there we have
been there where both of us are working
we don't have family in town and
inevitably something goes wrong your
nanny is sick a meeting runs long and
when you're stuck without your safety
net it can be a major issue and so I
started poppy not because I've had this
lifelong dream of
a childcare company I started poppy
because I had a problem and it was a
problem that I was convinced that
technology could help me solve but it
didn't matter that I have never worked
at a software company let alone build
one it didn't matter that I am NOT a
developer and had no way to build an app
and it really didn't matter that at the
same time I embarked on this journey was
the exact same time I decided to start
having kids all that mattered was that I
felt like parenthood was broken in a
little bit of a way you know Parenthood
is hard enough and when you are going
through all of these things I couldn't
imagine a future for future parents that
felt this broken and so for me it was if
somebody was going to be building a
future that solved this it might as well
be me and so that really was the genesis
for poppy where I thought I could use
technology to be able to solve a really
important problem that in my life but in
other people's lives and the thing is I
thought that if we could solve this so
today we're about ten people we are
thriving and we're growing really
quickly and if I look back on the
journey of the last three years from the
first very idea of poppy all the way
through to where we are right now I
think the thing that I reflect on is if
I let all those things that sort of
stood in my way all the reasons that why
I shouldn't be a founder kind of stopped
me from doing it poppy wouldn't exist
and that's sort of a shame it's more
than a shame it's a big important idea
that has to have its chance and so I
guess what I worry about is that how
many other people are focused on all the
ways and all the reasons and all the
obstacles that kind of stand in your way
instead of figuring out a path to how we
can figure out to build these amazing
companies so that's what I want to talk
to you today it's something that I'm
super passionate about if I think about
this last three years I think there's
sort of two big phases this sort of
phase one that I like to call kind of
get going
or live to fight another day and there's
the second phase which is get growing or
you know just proving that this concept
really can scale and so my hope is that
if we can talk about this openly the
stages even to get to where I am today
and there's so much more that we have
left to do so much exciting stuff for us
to do in the future but if I could get
even a hundred a thousand more companies
more founders to the stage that I am
right now
think about all the incredibles problems
we'll be solving think about all the
incredible founders will have and so
that's what I want to get to so that if
we can talk about this openly maybe we
make this journey a little less
mysterious a little less lonely and
definitely a lot more accessible so
that's what I hope to do today and share
just a couple of the things that I've
found not necessarily so intuitive and
hopefully in doing so we can start a
dialogue and start getting more people
started and going so to start before I
get to the idea of poppy a quick little
background on what brought me there my
background has nothing to do with tech I
actually have a pretty traditional
corporate career I started my career at
a company called Procter and Gamble they
make things like pampers and tide and
crest and when I started there I had the
opportunity to be trained in their
vision of brand management and what that
means is they taught me how to see
consumer problems not as consumers say
them and speak them to us but as they
actually experience them and that's a
really important distinction because
when you're trying to solve consumer
problems often people can't articulate
the real pain the real friction that's
going on in their lives and so I started
there I went on and I did my MBA did
consulting for a little while I
continued in sort of my big company path
all very traditional all the way through
to my husband and I moving to Seattle
and I was at Starbucks and still really
engaging really great career but I think
at that point for me my entrepreneurial
sort of bug had been I was bit by the
entrepreneurial bug and at that point I
said you know what I want to
start something it was about 2012 lots
of people are starting lots of
interesting things and for me I thought
I come from a world of retail e-commerce
and I have a great passion for you know
the world and culture and travel and now
that I had my first daughter
I was really also passionate about
passing that culture on to my kids and
so a friend and I started a company
called papaya and post it was a
subscription ecommerce company aimed at
raising culturally curious kids
basically think about a different month
a different culture done in a really
thoughtful I thought and engaging kind
of way
languages and food and things like that
and you know I did it in all the way
that did my research I did the numbers
did the business plan I did all the
things I were supposed to do built the
product that you know we would have
loved to have for our families and then
we launched it spent a lot of money and
a lot of timing relatively a lot of time
and as it turns out it was a beautiful
product people did think it was great
just know enough to buy it on a regular
basis and so that's a hard lesson for
those of you that have e-commerce
companies you always have to make sure
that customer acquisition cost for us
that was just too high we had such a
niche market of folks that had the
interest and the drive for a second
culture to share that with their kids
and then the LTV or the long term value
also wasn't there and that what that
means is just how many of those boxes
would they buy over their lifetime so we
learned the hard way that that just
wasn't in sync the customer acquisition
cost and the LTV and ultimately we came
to the decision to shut that down and
that was a hard process but I think the
right process because you have to be
true to what your intent is and my
intent has always been to build a
scalable company that disrupts a
category and again even for in my
background in my previous career it's
never been the what I've worked on
Footwear in apparel in foot and food and
Bev in healthcare my connection to that
has always been working on really
important consumer problems and in the
same way here for me I really wanted to
build a massive company that
took a massive swing at something and so
it was really hard because I thought I
did everything I was supposed to I used
up I had talked to my husband and I had
talked and basically said we could go a
year without you taking a salary and I
did used pretty much all of that year up
and I'd used a pretty much all of the
money that I'd set aside for startups
the savings that I'd put into this and
so that was sort of a tough position to
be in but as I started to talk to
parents about why wasn't this the thing
that you need it or it didn't solve a
problem urgent enough then what are the
problems in your life and I think it's
it's funny how themes just kind of come
up over and over and the thing that kept
on coming up was the topic of child care
and not really even oh I can't find a
nanny or my sitter just cancelled on me
what was underneath was everyone was
saying I miss my village I missed that
safety net of knowing I could text
someone that I trust and know that
they'll be there when I need them to be
you know for so many of us we move
around for our careers for our education
communities aren't necessarily what they
used to be you know asking a neighbor to
take care of for care for your child is
a hard thing and so we don't have those
villages but that function still is
necessary for us as parents and so as I
started to talk to more and more people
I could see the solution the way that I
talk about this is that I have a
chemistry undergrad and I think about it
in an equation if village is a function
of someone that you trust is a match for
is a fit for your family and is
available when you need them to be then
that can also be approximated with a
vetting mechanism a matching algorithm
and some sort of scheduler and so for me
I could already see how I could I had a
hypothesis on how I might approximate
village using technology at each of
these key kind of pieces which brings me
so to the point and the idea of papi and
so now if we think about that first
stage what is so important of get going
I had a couple of problems first of all
I could see how I wanted the solution
to happen but it was a tech in an app
solution and I am NOT a developer my
traditional background didn't have me
working with engineers so I didn't have
a co-founder ready and lined up and more
than that I had run out of basically
time and money that I had set aside
forget about myself but my agreement
with my family and my husband to go and
do this and so I guess the point is
there is that I was if it was already
constrained it was I was under lots of
more constraint and so if I think about
the first stage which is about getting
going the whole point here is about
validating if your idea matters and so
if I had this much all of these
different constraints how could I still
buy myself the time to validate the idea
and figure out whether I even needed to
worry about co-founders and tech and all
that kind of stuff and so my mantra was
pretty much just solved the thing in
front of me if I could solve the biggest
problem in front of me I'd figure out
the next one next and so in that
instance it was I needed to buy time to
do more things
so I basically basically to make give
myself some kind of structure I gave
myself the construct of four weeks can i
buy myself four weeks to be able to show
whether people want what I'm making
and so I approximated the whole flow
that I'm talking about using just
off-the-shelf things and that is one of
the most exciting things of living in
the tech world today is that there are
so many off-the-shelf solutions that for
very few things and especially for
consumer problems you can just literally
build something off the shelf and so I
did that for me what what am I trying to
do I am trying to connect vetted trusted
people with families when they have gaps
in care well so I found three u-dub
students vetted them in any way that
like is the top-of-the-line background
checks references in-person interviews
then I found 15 families in Madison Park
where I was living and I said hey if you
need a caregiver this week and you have
a gap in care just text this phone
number because SMS is a great
communicator and that day we got our
first booking and that week who we got
our first four so great I've got a
baseline I've
got four bookings and I just need to
grow it next week by 10% which is five
it doesn't sound like a lot but it's it
does two things one it's discipline if
you hold yourself to 10% growth every
single week I assure you that five grows
pretty quickly and then the other thing
is that having having a goal and then
hitting it and for me I because this
actually struck a nerve of something
that people really needed and wanted
we ended up growing faster than the 10%
in those early days so instead of five
we actually ended up at six and then so
on so forth and that is an incredible
confidence booster especially coming off
of a failure when you really don't have
any data points to suggest that you
should go give it another shot
and so the four week test for me did a
couple of things it reduced the risk for
me who's like I'm in a pretty
risk-averse person and it made it I
could I could devote for weeks and I
took it gave it the $200 that I had left
in my business bank account and I said I
can spend another $200 and by doing that
that sort of time bound and risk bound
to all of that and then as we got going
I could quickly see how consumer both
both sides just wanted and loved what we
were doing and so parents would tell
other parents signups would just start
coming in and I can't tell you how
different that is versus the first
startup when you're just trying to tell
everyone to do something and no one does
it and this one you're not even telling
anyone and they're just signing up and
the things are coming through and it
feels incredibly different and so that
was really important in the early days
is that when you're talking about
validating your idea your your purpose
is learning it's not about optimizing
for revenue or all of those things in
these early days you just have to pick
something and get going so for me that
meant you know just starting with some
kind of pricing mechanism that we think
you know made sense and just get into
market and so for me at the end of the
four weeks it literally was something I
couldn't shut down it had just gained a
life of its own which is amazing and it
felt really great but also when it's
just you doing all those things in a
pretty day
keyway you need to just keep it going
and so what those four weeks bought me
was not only time to keep on going but I
quickly realized what my next problem I
had to solve and that was I had to find
a technical co-founder and that made
that pretty apparent and so I continued
to keep everything going and growing to
be able to buy that additional time but
I quickly turned my attention to finding
a technical co-founder and I think I'll
pause on this thing because I think
there's a lot of you know women out
there that don't come from technical
backgrounds maybe don't have engineers
and I think there's a lot of options
open to us you can work with a dev shop
somewhere you can work with a contract
engineer you could even have a VP of
engineering that reports to you I have
I'm pretty biased but I have a strong
feeling that if your intention is to
build a tech company you have to have a
tech partner along your sell alongside
you and that means co-founder level that
means someone who's at the table of
constantly pushing each other on ideas
I'm non-technical so by definition I
cannot see the disruptive ways that
technology can solve this problem and so
for me even though I had all of these
folks that were saying that you know
either dev shops or other types of
engineers I was pretty clear that I
wasn't going to pursue those paths even
though it would have been a short-term
relief that would have sort of cut the
vision and the ambition of this idea off
at the knees and so I'm not saying that
this is easy this is one of the hardest
things I almost died and I've said this
before but we almost died through
growing too big too quickly without
somebody else to build the platform and
so it took probably about three or four
months and just constantly talking to as
many people as I could to find the right
person because again for those of you
that have a co-founder that's awesome
because you know how hard it is to find
these people that can be in the trenches
and be that lifeline for you there's of
course division of labor but beyond that
it's almost the emotional support
there's so many ups and downs on the
thing and so you can be the highest high
on one day and at noon the lowest low
and so you need sort of that partnership
to even that out
and so it took a couple months talked to
so many what feels like hundreds of
different candidates but finally I had
the chance to connect with my now
co-founder and CTO Richard and we ended
up clicking just right off the bat we
started talking about ideas really love
that but ultimately it came down to can
we work together and so we just set it
up again as a six-week test of like can
we work together can you build something
from a platform perspective and can we
work together and let's just see by
doing so again not a lot of talking we
just got to the first point of saying
are you in um are you in and just got
going that was really important because
by doing that we both were able to see
and assess whether we were good partners
whether we were both engaged in this
mission and this is something that we
could do together
I later learned and because this is also
one of those most common questions that
I'll get how did you find a technical
co-founder as it turns out by me
focusing on growth that also helped me
solve this problem because if you can
imagine for talented engineers think
about how many people are coming to them
and saying I've got an idea you need to
build it that's not awesome and so what
he was excited about was that I had
already started and got gotten going and
so he wanted to come on and you know get
onto that rocket ship and get get it
going even faster and further so that
solved my co-founder problem the next
thing was we needed money and so growth
also helps you with that because you can
dismiss me but you can't dismiss my
growth and so that helped when I applied
to YC in the interview I was able to
show the actual growth that people
actually wanted what I was making it
also ultimately helped us get our
incredible investors I'm not saying that
in raising money is ever easy but
certainly this time around because I
could focus on what we were building the
actual growth that was happening and
this wasn't me talking in ideas it was
really important and we were able to
raise that money so this stage one is
really about validate your idea get to a
hundred paying users that love what
you're making
and you'll be able to figure out and
just focus on growth you'll be able to
figure out the rest so stage 2 is about
get growing and get to a place where you
get to product market fit and you're
ready to scale a lot of this is about
growing up and into a company and I
found that my role as a founder sort of
had to shift from putting out fires and
just surviving to evening out into the
marathon that is a start-up and so this
for us started after we returned from YC
we raised our seed round of a little bit
over two million dollars and now we had
the chance and the space and the time to
actually build poppy into what it can be
so the first thing here is about hiring
about a team and I thought after 10
years of having experience you know with
big companies and hiring I thought I
knew how to do this and it took me many
months and many tries to realize I
didn't things like references things
like prior experience or pedigree of
what school you went to don't matter
that much what does matter is commitment
and resourcefulness passion for the
mission and one really great example I
like to share is about our head of ops
Rebecca at the time that she emailed me
just out of the blue she was a poppy
parent using poppy and she was just
intrigued at you know how what we were
doing and what we were up to and so she
just emailed me out of the blue and said
we'd love to grab coffee and I was
intrigued as well and loved to talk to
interesting people who are using our
product so I said why not and as I
talked to her and as we started to you
know just chat about all the challenges
I realized here's someone who maybe
hasn't done operations or worked at a
start-up but it's so engaged on the
mission knows it then what could be
better than having empathy for the
product firsthand and wanting that kind
of passion for doing it and so I think
in that I could repeat from so many
roles at our company so hiring becomes
less about pedigree or past experiences
or things like that but the people that
can prove to you that they have a
passion for your mission and your
problem and can get in and get going the
next thing is that you need to build a
company and it needs to even out you
need to do things that maybe you had a
hypothesis on different business model
things but now you need to
we have a sustainable business model and
so for us for example at the beginning
I'd started with a pricing thing where
we had a membership parents paid us
membership and then they just paid the
caregivers that worked but it didn't
work so well for us we didn't make
nearly enough money for us to be a
sustainable enterprise and so we had to
take the it's--it's pricing is always a
hard thing but we had to make the
decision that if we were gonna survive
we would have to take some cut of that
transaction or the hourly rate and so we
did we talked to tons of caregivers and
families we did all the research and we
you know built it into the systems and
we put it out papi did a lot of growing
up that week not because it wasn't the
right thing to do it was and it is but
because I think I'd underestimated how
much early users feel ownership of your
product and so we had never talked about
margin issues I had never talked about
some of the challenges of being in this
category so people felt blindsided and I
think the lesson that I took away that
day was those early users are a part of
your company and you need to bring them
in and you need to respect them with
transparency there's lots of these types
of examples but in this phase you are
going to need to do hard how to make
hard decisions to make your business
sustainable in the interest of having it
survive just be mindful of the fact that
make it as transparent and bring your
bring your users along through all of
those changes the last thing I'll just
touch on is to sort of it seems like
minor things but one is things like
investor updates and the other is
Mentors
there's a reason I didn't talk about
advisors and mentors in the first phase
it can be a distraction at that phase
you know what you need to do to validate
your idea there's no one else that can
tell you how to do that you just need to
get there in the trenches and do it but
the second stage as you as you settle
into the marathon you the founder need
to surround yourself with one - a couple
of people that you trust to be the
mirror to you because your job is to
always advocate for the mission and
everything like that but you need
someone to hold yourself accountable and
so having a couple of those folks that
don't necessarily agree with you on your
points of view but can push you on those
important things those are that's a
those are really important people to
have and then my quick point on investor
updates it feels like a little one but I
am always surprised at how few people do
it because it feels scary and it feels
like you know maybe I'm messing up and I
don't want everyone to know about it
it's important discipline to start as
early as possible and to be fair I
didn't do it until after YC but it's
important because again it holds you
accountable and it's the least that you
can do for your investors for the
privilege of their money so that's
basically what I feel like were the two
most important parts for stage one and
kind of Phase two for my company to get
to where it is today and I guess I feel
like if we can get so many more
companies and all of you to even that
stage I think that would be an
incredible kind of thing to get to the
last thing I'll just kind of touch on is
a couple of points of how to scale
yourself as a founder I think so many
people say being a founder is hard it is
it is hard for all the reasons that you
might expect in so many that you don't
the most important reasons I think is
because you need to be really sure you
want to be a founder and what I mean by
that is it isn't just the Sprint at the
very beginning or maybe the couple years
in you have to be sure you want to do
this for the next five ten years of your
life maybe it won't take that long but
you know often it does and so do you
want to devote your life to that great
answer that question next talk to your
family your spouse anyone else make it
very clear about your intention because
it's important to create the space to be
that founder because it's going to be
brutal and you need to be able to share
be sure that you can make that
commitment it's also okay if that answer
isn't maybe yes there's a lot of us
startups that could use amazing smart
people to work at our startups for a
couple of years until you figure out
whether that's the thing for you it also
gives you really amazing experience to
then start your startup at an advantage
the last point I'll make is you need to
take care of yourself I think for myself
because I'm a parent because I'm a
founder it is too easy to say I don't
have time for that
and I have learned through doing and
making this mistake that that is another
way to kill your company and what I mean
by that is you need to give yourself the
time to take breaks for me it's yoga and
that's sort of like a three-in-one for
me because it gives me a chance to sort
of work out give my mind a break and
just you know reassess and regen riajuu
Vinay because if you as a founder aren't
at your peak you can't provide everyone
else what they need and I think the the
parallel to Parenthood is really great
there I'm so many of us parents you know
just give and give and give and then you
realize you're just completely burnt out
it's the same thing with startups you
don't don't get yourself to that point
where you have nothing left to give and
you're burnt out and so if you make that
as a part of your practice and you
create that space I think that's just a
really important thing so YC
applications are due on March 24th that
is 50 days 7 weeks if you haven't
started that gives you two weeks to plan
something four weeks to do it and 1 week
to write the application if you have
started 7 weeks to go grow and that
application will just write itself in a
day my point is is that we need more
people standing on this stage at this
phase to even have a shot at all these
big bold problems that we all have so
let's get into that arena
let's build those big bold companies and
most of all let's stop focusing on all
those hurdles that lie in our way and
figure out how to just get started
you
you